the first pairs are finally ripe for
picking
like many German food farmers Thomas
Booker is worried about the consequences
of president Putin's import ban he
anticipates tougher competition on the
domestic market as producers from
neighboring countries try to find new
buyers for their fruit Pollan generates
almost 2 million tons which makes it
Europe's leading producer six hundred
eighty thousand tons are normally
earmarked for Russia but now our polish
counterparts are going to try and sell
their goods in Western Europe and then a
good harvest year like this one that's a
problem
Greece is also likely to be hard hit by
the economic sanctions among other
things it traditionally supplies Russia
with olives and peaches the loss of that
business is tipped to cost the already
beleaguered country some 178 million
euros Italy doesn't stand to fare much
better with Russia no longer willing to
buy its fruit and vegetables the
southern European state is looking at a
vast surplus and at a loss to the tune
of 250 million euros the import ban
caught the German farmers association
off guard even though business with
Russia was already on a downward turn as
an actually India massive eateat compact
in terms of scale it came as a big
surprise but over the past one or two
years Russia has indicated a desire to
move away from the European market for
the time being the shelves are still
full of European goods there's
everything from Finnish milk to Dutch
cheese and there's no immediate sign of
food shortages but that could change
Russian consumers have responded to that
prospect in different ways it's bad news
for me I don't want to go back to the
way it was in the 90s we have to
strengthen domestic production import
goods aren't healthy anyway the
supermarket manager is already
considering how to restock we will
replace the goods that are affected by
the import ban with our own products
from countries that have not imposed
sanctions on Russia Russia is going to
need new suppliers president Putin's ban
is initially in place for one year and
applies to meat fish cheese fruit and
vegetables from the EU Canada the US and
Australia
alternative in poor countries for
poultry fish fruit and vegetables our
Brazil Chile and Argentina cheese could
come from New Zealand
back in Brandenburg Thomas Bruckner is
sorting his produce some 20% was
supposed to go to Russia but like other
German farmers he will have to find new
markets since extinction I think there
could be possibilities in Asia and
Africa we could certainly start moving
in that direction but that requires
preparation time and most importantly
political stability and that's not
necessarily the case in those regions at
the moment the German farmer is hoping
the government will compensate him for
his loss of earnings but whether Berlin
or indeed Brussels will be forthcoming
with such support is far from clear